I just think it's dope too because like
you always will hear that like the bay
doesn't get enough credit and that's
true in terms of influence in terms of
culture in terms of just everything that
they've brought to the game and me and
gazi always have these conversations
about like how back in the day there was
so much music industry
in San Francisco in the Bay Area you had
Jive Records Was there and you had a lot
of a lot of people would have offices
around the city and I guess like what's
kind of missing is like representation
of media right on a bigger scale right
right
um so I think it's dope to like you saw
that like hey I'ma just do this [__]
myself you know definitely and um like I
said with my [__] um
like I just feel like my [__] is is
authentic bro like my [__] is pure like
I don't get people on my [__] and ask
trying to stir [__] out start [__] I'm
not looking for no viral moment right
like I always tell people all the time
my viral moment is what we sitting there
building and we having a conversation
and you may say some [__] that somebody
is going through you get what I'm saying
and that might spark a flame in them to
change their life or they probably was
thinking about suicide and they didn't
commit suicide because they looking at
okay damn if little blood going through
this [__] you feel me and this is how
you handle it I can get over this [__]
too so that's my final moment all right
looking for no click bait we don't do
click bait we don't do none of that [__]
I might drop an interview and the [__]
don't do no numbers you feel me but the
shorter take off right yeah yes for sure
the real or the shorter yeah so all
right I'm doing my job bro like I said
I'm not on that fake [__] we don't do
that at talking media we don't
um push [__] we you know we
articulture and we're not trying to gain
off the culture and we're not trying to
exploit the culture you get what I'm
saying for sure man I think I I that's
what I think I told I think uh one of
the like I think the Russell interview I
saw you do was just incredible I was
like this [__] is dope thank you
Marshawn shoulders though I didn't see
the new Marshawn
um interview but obviously we just
filmed it we haven't dropped the check
it'd be very hard for anybody to get the
Marshawn Lynch interview you guys for
sure man this other one the second one
like I said that's like
um that was brother you know at the end
of the day uh you know we help each
other like from the fan first shout out
fam first shout out Josh Johnson shout
out Marcus Peters shout out all them
guys over there at fam first it's like a
family thing you know I'm I'm doing um
fundraisers I'm helping them uh with
talent shows or you know whatever it is
maybe what date doing I'm in full
support of it so whatever I do they are
in full support of it and it's all the
way love type [__]